I didn't do anything on it but yeah
what's
up oh look who it is hey we how big
Chris is getting dude he's
on he's on I'm not actually but if I was
it would be trouble right he's so your
voice is your voice is super deep dude
I'm jacked what a guys his feet why why
do you have a turnout like platypus I'm
flexible I don't even realize what's
going on he got a he got a full chest
piece like a prospect in the H he has a
he has a a mountain range it's a
mountain range so there's an eagle
flying and a mountain range behind it
and then he's got glass he got at the at
the line at Disneyland when they were
giving it out oh my friend oh my friend
hey tell me we should beat him up yeah I
would love to just give you a soccer out
you know what if you beat me up I
wouldn't even care bro make your feet
normal penguin want you to know how
flexible I am dude and it's on dude sit
down I'm back on fighing the kid dude we
it again the F in theid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby last
one I did dude 1997 guest of the year we
did dummy numbers 1997 guest of the year
don't say don't say dummy numbers wait
we did we went stupid right we did Dum
we went St people saw it and they go oh
that's what they did I don't think
anybody did stupid they did they went
dumb and these glasses that's hilarious
you say that they're from Disneyland cuz
they're not
you not listen you you dress like my son
okay what is
that I can't have okay yeah yeah I got
my own deal
going oh a sword dud do with a
Scabbard it's different now Captain
hooker no look you dropped your special
it's different now I got a sword yeah I
know I dropped my special and it's
different now hey
hey I'm going to say this I'm going to
make this I'm going to make this
statement had to buy something grower
die now listen you the merch is litty
though hey not for the Boomers right not
for the Boomer here what do you mean the
the merch is litty I merch grow or die
at chia.com what were you going to say I
was going to say that I believe in my
heart if you had that Scabbard and we
had to fight I could take that Scabbard
away from youve it no yeah you know what
I would do I would faint you don't even
know what a faint is and you go like
this like that and then I faint what you
do when you fain's what you do when you
see a really nice [__]
right you
go isn't that right dude I wasn't I need
this dude cuz [__]
different yeah my thing came out ah [__]
talk about stupid numbers crystalia dcom
dude are you doing dummy numbers a [__]
man Netflix who dude don't use this
podcast I know I I should right but I
got this in case of intruders because
[__] is different now but where did you
get the sword did they send it to you
cuz you hit guy left it up my house at
my Halloween party he was a pirate but I
will tell you this okay I got when I
when he did that I looked at it and I go
[__] is going to be different and so I
didn't give it back to her have you
studied any kind of Sword Play No No in
if Intruders come cuz dude there's a lot
of love out there for my special but
there's also a lot of hate and I need in
case Intruders come am my sweetheart at
home she was like thank you just say
your wife I know no no I know but call
her sweee my sweetie doll at home she
goes my she didn't actually say it but
her energy was my hero and I say
I got it in case of intruders she says
should we set an alarm after I got off
of the floor for laughing 45 minutes I
said we don't need no stinking alarm and
I took this out and she goes and she
basically said my hero okay I I I have a
request okay I have a request I'm coming
from my groundbreaking podcast off
limits from speaking to from a very
changed the name again yeah it's called
off limits cuz the [__] I talk about is
off limits bro
called off air guys
beol guys be cool about my my newest
effort about La branding what is it it's
called what is ite called off limits cuz
the [__] I deal with is off limits cuz
it's off limits cuz the inter so stupid
no it's not off limits no no it's like
dangerously off limits but listen oh
yeah dude yeah cuz I'm changing the
conversation now listen oh yeah man yeah
be don't do that hey you know what I
heard though was in Casey's office right
next to and I hear they W the interview
and Brian goes you know Joe Rogan guy
goes yeah Brian goes man I got to get
you in with him hey bro don't toss I
didn't say that that was based on a
conversation that happened beforehand
about that you're taking everything out
of context let me get to my point you're
saying it's fake news no let me get to
my point [__] look I just came from
having a very deep conversation once
again on my ground breaker stor and
stuff like that I'm changing the
conversation I'm one of the I'm I'm
immersing myself in the best it's been
thought and said I I I come from a world
of substance I'm begging you to make
this podcast at least a little
substantive oh God yeah this one so I
can give me some meat I can chew on Hey
listen man you want substance you go to
crystalia decom you want fun in games
and you
want you want you know what I mean and
that's that's honestly I haven't even
thought about the backstory of the
character I my but already
this you know I'm talking I don't think
a pirate that's not what I consider to
be like a a harbinger of good stuff
educate him on how Pirates Were Gay lot
of [__] that went on so so and do you
know why because they were all in the
same boat and if I was on the same boat
with a bunch of dudes you know how long
it would take me to start [__] guys 8
days I've thought about this
we're three Pirates we're three Pirates
we're at se I don't know 6 months who's
getting [__] first well we'll get into
that you're well no I'm not me me hey
with him Callen Callen you might not get
smashed a lot but using your
mouth hey you have to know in prison I'm
trading you for cigarettes right you use
we using your mouth dud what do you want
to do you want to go you want hey you
want to go overboard or you want to come
this way no no either way he's not going
to be able to breathe who made you a
shot caller in prison or on the high
seas I'm talking about on the and I
haven't even thought about me backstory
dude do you understand what I'm saying
no I don't understand what you're saying
chrisa got a sword dude nobody said that
yeah dude they were they did outside of
Aran
I didn't know where I was going with
this now it's okay man if we're on the
high
sea hey hey here's my joke Hey guys
you're getting dick and scurvy that's
what you're get that's what you're
getting hey you better eat some fruit
and stop sucking dick you're about to
get some scurvy hey I'm losing my teeth
I haven't got any vitamin C my teeth are
falling out that's all right Brian it's
better for us yeah I got some this is
pirate humor right here yeah dude let's
write a [__] movie called Gay on the
high seas yeah what what what yeah they
did one with brokeback mouth I want
youro I want yours oh nice one for
Cowboys you could do they should do one
for
gangs uh they're like a gay gang banger
hey hey dog hey wait you let me ask you
something I'm not I I know I look tough
I've never had a run in with any I'm
just trying to think of like if I C if I
was casting a movie M you are not I
can't cast you as the hero you just
don't you're just the ne tattoo not
anymore dude you just look your your
whole face is you're you are you're
unconventionally charismatic so there's
something going on but overall you're
not a hero I'm getting behind right if
so if there's a dangerous situation the
[__] zombies are coming I'm gonna get
behind him because he he's got a
mustache but he was UFC guy big guy
strong guy sure yeah but in no situation
there's no situation where there's a
dangerous situation where we go what the
[__] the tsunami is coming the Pirates
are coming zombies let's get get Chris
no where's Chris nobody's getting behind
you right before we die but first of all
he's not stopping his tsunami either a
bad example it's a bad example but I'm
saying an emergency there's an
earthquake tornado put the volcano put
the volcano given a salari to a volcano
hey put a [__] Kimora on a on a
[__] dud oh no dude here comes a wave
dude getting Kachi [__] off man you're
dying no matter what what I am saying is
if it's mmy comes you want me there
because until we die we're having a
laugh dude we are having a ball and I
will right through that tsunami D no no
you know what happens with you if
there's an emergency and we're like
let's go we got to get out of here and
you're like I need a nap no dude I wet
myself is that a real uh
sword holy [__] you brought that sword a
guy left it at my [__] Halloween
party and he put it in my bedroom
because my kids were at home and said I
forgot there were kids here so let me
put my real pirate sword in your bedroom
and he did and then when he left I
didn't remind him about the pirate sword
because I wanted
it so he stole it also he shouldn't
bring a real sword to your home no [__]
dude but he's my tattoo guy he's crazy
dude okay he's crazy so he he did a lot
of my pieces dude and he left this piece
there and I'm [__] dude I'm so Jack
man and you wanted it and you said you
let him forget I let him forget he go he
in his you know how you know how you
know I didn't forget cuz when he left I
waved at him and I said bye and I looked
right in his eyes he had a full pirate
outfit on and I just go see you dude see
you later in my head thought bubble
sword me just it's different now
thinking about bits dude I'm thinking
I'm going to kill this [__] on Instagram
see you dude and he goes IR made his H
long [__] limping with the peg leg
and I go that shit's mine now and as he
left he went like
this yep and you shot a video pretend to
be Britney Spears for special I didn't
even think about that actually but it
was a lot have you seen his his big
sloppy [__] in that thing well it's
bunched up but go ahead and pull it up
that's the first thing I noticed just
this lazy it curls up it curls up like a
Viper dude you have to because it you
have to you have to Quick let's take a
little break we need a break from
christalia little break a tad but you
know when I when I want to take a break
like if I if I'm in the middle of meals
but I want to keep my satiety down do
you reach for candy a lot of people
reach for candy a lot of fast food a lot
of people reach for fast food what you
do to get Macadamia I knew you holding
out on me dude Omega 7 fatty acids some
of the best fat profile you can get on
nuts no sugars no I'm talking about pure
macadamia nuts that's your secret yeah
but dude you got to be a billionaire to
afford those nuts unless you go to house
academia.com
macademia macademia Macadamia you know
what's crazy I love nuts you know I love
me to some nuts but I was drinking black
coffee the other day I went dude I wish
I had some macadamia nut milk so you get
Macadamia money go to go to a fancy uh
Supermarket you got that yeah grocery
store and buy Macadamia nutmilk and go
ahead and tell me how much that costs or
or milk it milk them yourself takes
forever oh that takes a long time milk
in one little nut not a lot of milk hard
to do but you can get a gallon a free
gallon of macademia nut milk a gallon
macademia milk pure macademia milk when
you visit house academia.com
TFA okay you just add the milk to your
cart with any products and use code TF a
k get the best nuts you can get pure
macademia nuts you can get them
chocolate covered white chocolate
covered raspberry uh raspberry C covered
it's unbelievable they're they're
they're As Good As It Gets and they are
according to a lot of scientists
considered probably the healthiest nut
they're so tasty that's House of
mamas.com
TFK and you get a free gallon of
macademia milk when you visit I can't
wait for UFC 295 I just wish I could
watch Saturday dude this Saturday oh man
is that one you got two title fights on
the line you got Yi don't say Jerry
right you got Yi you got Alex pier and
you also got Tom Aspen and Sergey bav
we got a fight got a heavyweight belt on
the line interm which should be for the
regular belt you have the light
heavyweight who you got be okay you want
you want you want me to give you the
odds yes so Yi is a slight favorite he
was like minus 115 when we last checked
yeah and then Tom asol is like a minus
135 so the odds are pretty even yeah I
got I got Aspen and I I got Pier me too
you got it you got to go we're the same
so there's no bets there uh but you can
parlay them and make bank with our
friends at DraftKings all right and and
they're giving you guys one heck of a
deal this offer is only at draftking
Sportsbook new customers strike now to
get $200 instantly in bonus bets when
you bet $5 R get in on the UFC 295
action with draftking Sportsbook the
official sports betting partner of the
UFC download the app right now use the
code fighter new customers get 200
instantly in bonus bets when you bet $5
that's code fighter only at draftking
Sportsbook the crown is yours gambling
problem call 1 1800 Gambler or visit
www1 1800 gambler. in New York call 8778
Hope NY or text Hope NY 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 78977 777 or
visit ccpg dog please play responsibly
on behalf of booill Casino and Resort KS
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction void
in Ontario o NT uh bonus bets expire 168
hours after issuance C sportsbook.com
draftkings.com MMA terms for eligibility
and deposit restrictions terms and
responsible gaming resources I sent uh I
sent my uh oh yeah there you go all I
saw was Dick first oh yeah okay so it's
buch man your body's soft around the
middle no I'm not hey John Wayne bar
said your sword looks cold look at his
at what he said my sword looks cold John
Wayne par said that been for less than
24 hours and you come home with a sword
[__] is different now look at how
ridiculous you are with your your
Eagle dude look how [__] cool I am
man and I put it
out
myself so now you know who why you
flexing dude she's married to that I got
a I got a sword she's married to that
you have kids I I guess I don't see the
correlation like you put it out yourself
it's amazing best special you've ever
done h thank you but you're not just
saying that cuz I'm I have a sword too
right no I'm saying it both reasons
yeah check out this part one thing is
cool you could Intruder comes in cuz my
special is so dope that Intruders might
come in and if they come in I could
slice them and this way when I slice
them the thing where there's a good
point they think I I think you think I
missed I slice him you think I missed
and then after a beat they just
go
you ever seen Ghost Ship what happens in
Ghost Ship dude and you just slic them
up dud that's you cut him this yeah they
don't know and then you go you
go enemies just all sorts
enemies Morty no different they're all
just like and you go oh no you look like
you're waving a flag is [__] now and
they all go like
this and they and and I realized that I
saved the day
dude hey to be honest though all jok
side we how long you know
I I way too long but but probably
probably 15 years probably 10 the he's
this the best shape he's been in [__]
yeah dude best best comedy you've ever
done thank you that special was really
good for it but I don't think he's in
great shape I sent it to him you pay for
it no I got it for free I got it I sent
it to him because he asked I would send
it to you but you didn't ask I illegally
stream it oh that's okay uh you're
you're your people are buying it a lot
yeah yeah yeah yeah
great I said people I wouldn't say he's
in good shape he's just put on he's
eating back to the compliments he did
pistol squats he did a bunch of pistol
squats I know and then he'll show me we
we at Whole Food like can you do this
like what yeah yeah I am a maniac I go
100 miles an hour uh and I'm into
working out now so I'm doing it 100
miles hour yeah you don't do any uh like
diesel no sport no no of course not no
Sports You' never done a sport but also
I did dude but you're not you never done
any with a ball can you throw a football
have you ever that's dumb kid [__] man
okay kid [__] but you what you doing
like death let's play catch I'm like I
can't okay no dude then you're going be
like let me call Uncle Bryan he comes
over to Tesla and kids like absolutely
not now let's call Uncle Brandon right
if we want to bring in the big don't be
a dick call Uncle I can [__] oh
Brian's driving here how do you know cuz
you can't hear him and the [__]
tesser no I can this is the sound of a
Tessa yeah but you know what you hear
that's me throwing a spiral right I
thought you say that's your car no
that's what that's me throwing a
spiral I dude I'm not going to throw oh
I broke my fingers what's that oh
couldn't catch it it's me fast release I
know know yeah like that how come you
can do that that's some real old man
[__] huh yeah can anyone do that under
the age of 50 no it's a boomer I can tie
knots too Boomer wh I cane yeah I can do
all kinds of weird [__] tie knots do
that my mom can do
used to do that [__] or can you do this
one where where you put
the oh old school I can I can really wh
That's great dude can you do that chin
you're not you know young that's really
great Brian that you can do that I'm
really proud of you the only time my
father ever ever kind of was like a
little envious of me where we were
trying to catch a cab and he's like this
and I go like that cab stops and he goes
Jesus how do you I've always wanted to
be able to do that and I was like well
too bad the reason why I didn't come on
this podcast before is cuz I hated that
pinstripe thing what oh you know what we
we get that a lot what do you mean oh
really we get that a lot what a lot what
do you what do you everyone's like dude
we've been waiting for you to change the
background and now dude for us we change
the background things are different yeah
exactly you want the sword dude this
looks way this looks dope it looks dope
yeah
so
shoot you how are things going on your
how's the Pod dude it's going good man
I'm out there I'm just you know got my
heart in it and just out there leing in
myself and it's is great be sincere no
everything's good man I get out there
and I just give it my all dude I sit
down hold on one po at a I write
about give the kids something
substantive like say something say
something that that we can learn from
okay everybody what are you thinking
about I've been thinking a lot about
what's going on in the world okay give
us so that's just
what's your Take On The World sit oh God
it's in a dire state but I will tell you
this man I think it's crazy that in 2020
all that stuff went down politically and
then now we're going to be right back
there and it's funny cuz if you look at
videos from even a long time ago we're
still talking about the same issues and
no matter who you are what race color or
Creed you can identify with what they're
talking about because why because we're
all part of the human race right oh
Jesus I like it you got to have me
though yeah being super so whether you
are in the Middle East or just you know
in the east in the valley uh in the
Middle East or just the regular East
yeah you can all identify with the fact
that uh no I you know no
racism you're not RAC I almost didn't
come here cuz there's no blacks I almost
didn't come here I show in and I go like
this I say I say chin isn't enough we
need not just sinis dude it's a Melting
Pot she agrees with me then whether
you're in the Middle East or theast or
the regular East that's beautiful and so
she really likes my sword have you ever
seen Prince of Persia but dud he oh God
think about the staff here you got Asian
we got you know Asians don't count
persan Persian ASI we got we got the
young demo we got the you know the the
white trash right and then we got we got
Mexican Asian Persian inbr you guys have
the
[__] Boomer you right now listen
pasty white let's let's let me let me
ask you a couple questions so we know
what we're dealing with okay what what
are the two countries Gaza
borders I'm not falling into that trap
my friend what do you mean nice try we
are not talking about that in-depth here
because it's not in depth I'm literally
asking you a simple question we can't go
below or above because we will just get
shredded dude man you want the real
stuff you go to crystal.com but you have
been pushed to the right a little bit
right
it's hard to
stay in the middle yeah there you go
it's hard to stay in the middle when
they keep moving the
goalposts take it easy there he goes
yeah take it it's hard it's like you
know it's like you used to be able to
say certain words and they change the
words on you you'll say the word and
then you'll be like you can't say that
anymore and you go why and they say just
not acceptable anymore and you just go
does that make you
angry oh no what are you doing he
sprouting
wings oh [__] two two Wings
two two two right
wings I keep flying in a
circle oh you can't say [__]
anymore but just in a circle yeah they
used to say [__] on
commercials
they did dude yeah they did yeah it's a
weird time so I'm just saying we're all
getting older mhm I'm really old but you
guys are in your 40s soon to be mid 40s
how old are you now 40 you're only 40
young I'm a young you're still young is
40 young 40 30 is what they not young
Stallone I watched that that special I
mean his documentary were very good and
he goes um you know after 40 40 is your
gaining and then after 40 it's kind of
lost
you know you're losing your your
physical prime you're losing you're
losing you know friends get married and
move on all kinds of stuff yeah we have
about four friends left yeah but that's
kind of what happened three of them are
in here and then he was even saying I
thought that was a good documentary
because he was saying trying to stay
relevant and realizing that he did so
many movies he goes oh he he SE things
25 movies and he goes if I knew I only
had 25 movies to make in a lifetime you
think I would have done all these and he
was pointing all the movies that
he said you know he created Rambo he
created Rocky too and he's a genius if
you hear how he knows how much he's a
genius he's a
[__] so when he wasn't doing when he
wasn't doing action movies where he was
yeah but he did action movies where he
wasn't saying much and he and he said he
goes he goes a lot of people think they
can do everything you can't you can do a
couple things right and that's it but
then he goes and here I am in this house
and he goes all my kids have moved on
yeah and now I'm kind of in a big empty
box is it but is he still with his wife
yeah cuz that one I assume that one's A
better ending than the Arnold one Arnold
one makes it's so much better one you're
like oh cuz right he had he had a baby
with the with the ma and he's he's
talking to his donkey at the end he's
just like Fe the donkey oh he's he's in
a castle by himself he's basically
Shrek with a donkey shone's family they
have a very good great family they have
very I know his daughters are great the
daughters are amazing I guess
kid Studio I didn't yeah I didn't know
they did yep I didn't know that um uh he
had lost his son I didn't know that
stone did yeah his son died of a heart
attack it wasn't drugs it he died of a a
heart attack in just randomly How old uh
he was like 28 or something horri it's
horrible well you know you you and I
have all have kids when somebody loses a
child you're like oh my God
Sage uh and he never talks about it I
guess yeah I didn't even know that's
horrible yeah he can't
um there's still and now those were the
those were the tango and cash days which
is my favorite I love the truck he's
always doing something good though
that's why I think like he's an
Expendable the what do you call it the
Tulsa King are you kidding me I didn't
see
it he's so fun yeah he's great he's
great he's great great Taylor Sheridan
wrote that yeah he crush on Tulsa King
what else is he in uh he does
Expendables so he talked about
Expendables so he's that's the other
franchise he comes up with so he's s
yeah and he's and he's and so he's
watching oh he's a genius when you see I
know he keep he is and he he made
the were you there when he took us on a
on a tour of his uh of his was I there
dude he invited me and you came okay hey
hey hey hey dude and then he did a post
and Spilled Brian's name wrong yeah
Brian Callahan dude I'll tell you this
much man he did Harry Potter he did Star
Wars and he he he did Blind Side too he
did Blind Side he did do blind he did so
he's he's watching the he went to some
Revival of like they had like lead
Zeppelin Rolling Stones whatever just
all these old rockers and he's looking
at them and they're all doing their
music and he goes boy these guys are all
done just like we're same agear yeah
he's like wow and he's like but they're
still rocking and people are still
loving it right they're still playing
the like nostalg and he goes why can't
we do this for action figures why can't
Heroes why can't we take all the action
heroes from the 80s and 90s and make a
movie and that's where he did expend
yeah dude is Chuck Norris in Expendables
uh was one see what the first one he's
probably in it the first one was like
The A Team that and that was is that the
one that Rampage was in too The
Expendables and it's like Randy gor him
Mickey Ro Terry Cruz Randy cout DOL jet
Ley come on Jet Lee Looks Like A Lady
huh Stone Cold Steve a what's that all
about straight up looks like my ant come
on dude Mickey Ro looks like my Aunt
there yeah we'll make work Eric Roberts
he's great and that's it that on that
list no no no prer Barbosa is in
it oh
little little nog's in it little who was
that big or little I don't know that's
little it looks
like and they're on their fourth
franchise they just did their fourth one
yeah I don't watch them if it's just
action no story I'm out no that's what
I'm into I know St I don't want stupid
story it all sucks I just want him
fighting and shooting dude oh Jesus
what's your favorite movie my favorite
movie of you're saying of all time top
five favorite movies oh top five
favorite movies yeah uh the first uh
four Robocop and then five would be the
Englishman who went up a hill but came
down a mountain beautiful story dude I
there's only three RoboCop well no not
if you count the one with Joel kman but
I oh no those don't
count I want to talk about your tattoos
go ahead man shoot you have so many you
uh you might have more tattoos Than Me
Now full SLE start in their team you
started in your 40s wouldn't it be a
good idea to start when you already when
you end up knowing yourself and who you
are he's right about this I have a lot
of tattoos when I was like 16
17 on your [__] ankle or some [__]
well that one's cool but the other ones
I regret football Kings things like that
well no freshman of the year that one's
cool but they're all kind of trophies on
my body but I didn't have money at the
time so he went to a guy and he's like
100 bucks I'm like I have 80 he's like
we'll do it and then it's nightmare I
remember you would if I left you alone
for a little while you'd come back with
a tattoo oh yeah now let's go through
these tats but he has fancy tatto the
people what what would you get if you
were going to get a tattoo elephant ear
here elephant ear here no I wouldn't get
and people be like why does elephant
have such a small truck Dum joke I have
a you could do a play on Tulsa King get
Tesla King and then awesome dud and then
across your back but [__] me oh W very
subtle too I saw I think it's like this
I was in I was in a movie trailer I
won't say his name but he was a he was a
he had been a Seal Team Six captain of
SEAL Team Six Squadron and was uh had
been through a lot of [__] had been
through a lot of [__] for he was like in
the in seals for like 10 years as a Seal
Team he seen some [__] and he took his
shirt off he took his shirt off he just
took his shirt off and his back looked
like a maum it looked like it was all
religious all religious iography special
force guys they have like a a number and
there's like a bullet next to or a skull
I don't want that yeah this guy I ask
him I'm going say his name because he
he's a great guy Justin Sheffield
remember when he said I wasn't going to
say I'm not going to say his name I
don't want to give this guy I think it's
okay it's okay you you said it he just
got assassinated but straight up you
know what Justin Che Justin ch's like
this or cuz you're dumbass dude I know
well that's how I spill the beans but he
uh he literally that that guy right
there that that who had been through a
Spartan a Spartan had been through what
he has a a beard that's very rare for
those guys that's yeah yeah that's him
right there Kristen wouldn't Sho on me
with that guy so it's okay yeah just but
but he took a shirt of and he his it's
that that religious econom damn he's
changed yeah wow that's what agel do it
to you wow he leaned out I saw him right
when he was out of you know the service
and he just was a those special forces
guys tats are different bro different
it's like when you see a cartel guy
different TX in a way you're like oh you
earn that religious
you've so close to life and death that
you've earned that whole it looked like
a like a medieval ceiling that somebody
had painted and I was like damn so
unless I a cabin yeah let's get through
let's go through your tattoos now okay
so let's I got no fear about that
okay man man I don't need you to sit I
can't relax on don't do that let me see
what's the first tattoo let's go with
let's go with your right
arm now what's on your
wrist you got a dinosaur skull you got a
what's that what's that lotus flower
yeah and it says awake right there and
then I got an elevator you're awake now
you're you've you've you're awake uh it
it uh it's not done I'm going to put up
above it I'm going to put I hate being
a so I'm so tired I'm getting all these
damn dude you got to get more more
protein and you know and more I do my
podcast I pull my heart in it I go out
there and I sit down in my in my studio
I think and I go through all the stuff
the
news and I appreciate you watching
congratulations and
also golden hour I think you and also
Lifeline so thank
you that sounds okay so this is a
triceratops for my I talk about my
special Chris lea.com all right yeah
there's a a story about that with your
son son loves din dinosaurs yes uh and
then this is actually a cool one this is
my my my grandfather sold newspapers on
this um
doubtful made up on this street made up
my dad had that never Happ when he was
used to help guys never happen sorry
Italian immigrant what's that yes yeah
from where body just say Bari I know I'm
I'm cultural dude I say B wait so that's
the cross streets of where he well not
in Italy but yeah in Times Square he
used to do it yeah bu oh so he sold
newspapers in Times Square and you got
the cross street yeah because a lot of
really be I love my grandpa uh and he
had what did he he had a stand there he
had a stand and that was demolished but
not his
memory what are the what are the cross
streets uh 33rd and 7th 33rd and what
7th right there you know Time Square
that's not Time Square no it's not Time
Square you said Time Square okay well I
[__] up3 cuz that's just some Corner
okay it's not some corner it's near
Union Station okay hey Chris look at us
look at us hey my boy knows New York
right bro your heart bleeds you talking
about Pen Station yeah what I say say
Union Station all right well whatever
bro that's in [__] D okay it's fine
you made up the whole story it is what
it is I fell asleep and this is what
happened you're you're panicking do you
think you lied about that tattoo like I
lied about using Just For Men oh God
this is a street corner I used to get
butt [__] in
Pennsylvania
you yeah you we we'll get to your
mustache in a little bit cuz I I want to
talk about that what's wrong with it no
we we'll talk we'll talk it's not that
something's wrong with my Saddam Hussein
right yeah well you you look very very
Mario Brothers Italian right you
do it's me
Mario so you got that so now let's keep
going well that looks like a budoir or
something what is that what the that's a
vending machine it's a vending machine a
[__] dumb waiter dude it's an
elevator why'd you get an elevator on
your [__] forearm I the wding what
what you Wen bro you know why he had a
[__] show was a staircase taken no I
got that too
oh you got a stair you got a wa an
elevator and a staircase does that
signify you could take the elevator and
get there faster or you could walk which
is better for you I can't wait to get an
escalator
dude my why' you get a staircase
[__] a Mac store and
[__] I don't want to talk about it you
know what I mean see I can't believe you
entertain it I don't entertain it if you
have if you have if you got a tattoo
what would you
get I've thought about this I bet he was
supposed to get a tattoo when we hit 10
million downloads that was a long time
ago but he supposed to do made some
money you have a thing going CH yeah it
sucks [__] man I even have it on silent
but it breaks through sometimes just let
you know when they algorithm gets to
chat backed up I supposed breaking the
sound barrier and whenever I go whenever
I deposit money into my do you know
what's [__] crazy
man I was walking around and my pants
were falling down and I was like what
the [__] why did my pants keep falling
down they were they were actually
falling down and I go what's going on
it's annoying I Ty my belt this and that
I they fall down [__] I'm like all right
I got to I my pockets what's phone I
took my phone out they stopped falling
down and I'm like well that doesn't make
much sense right because my phone's
always been the same weight dude I
realized my Wells Fargo app was getting
heavy oh my God isn't that
stupid so stupid you're so stupid I go I
go and make a deposit my far stupid
you're so stupid my dick would come out
cuz of my we no people see my dick
because I go I make a deposit makes
sense is that weird butterfly effect man
that's butterfly you have a mountain
peak on your
throat it's a butterfly there um that
was the newest one if I if I got a
tattoo it would say you were supposed to
get one B I was eight years ago when we
had 10 million 10 million views eight
years ago you crossed 10 million
downloads and you didn't get it and now
you're at 10 and a half million
downloads and I can't believe you still
don't I can't damn it I would get uh I
don't know man I would get I feel like
you got to get something like I don't
know some that really matters like you
can't get fir the kid
probably everything about this you know
what you do hly on your on your on your
rib cage or right near it you just go
deah made it
twice twice
yeah made it twice or what about a
phoenix like you're coming out your
lashes your face you're lucky if you
make it once theah made it
twice you me say no I'm not getting that
he should get a phoenix because I'm
about I'm a substantive person and I'm
looking to talk substant ly right now
cuz my groundbreaking podcast off limits
oh God where I really get to the issues
I wish talking about it was off limits
dude [__] your podcast is called off
limit he's tried it for 10 years it was
the Brian
C I know it's it's not
General it sounds [__] like what the
what is this oh no dude I'm tired of
being in the limits I want to go what
the [__] is this Li your and yeah break
the limit the other good thing is that
everyone can find it right cuz it's not
behind a pay wall or well half of it you
can find everywhere and the other half
you'd have to go to The Mug CL it so
half of it's legit off limits yes half
of it legit off limits there's a limit
to get to it yeah yeah yeah there's that
yeah I I I just don't know what I would
get as a [__] tattoo I want a tattoo
do you I don't have the skin for a
tattoo I just don't know if I think it's
tougher to tattoo on skin cuz yours is
loose right no oh no he guys just like
why is it
funny it's like ttoo on everybody's
elbow guys guys I have tight I that's
just your ball sack no I have that's
your throat that's his
neck I think I would get like a [__]
pistola ohed in tued in you got that
idea from chevchenko dude [__] is that
what he has two gun like this oh he has
a p Chef chenko a honestly [__]
aside double pistolas double
pistolas double
ma
okay okay that's what I would get and
then I would get I would get you on your
I'd get a real life thing of you on your
stomach I don't think so dude naked and
just peeling your
Peach during your I don't think so I'm
actually asking Jesus Christ if that
would happen
hey what are you doing what did he say
you're taking guys let's take a magic M
break okay let's take a magic M break
you had this give me one B what try this
I could use it try magic mine and in all
honesty tell me how you feel after BR
stop saying try magic mine bro I love
magic mine I take it all the time you're
dumb you know I do he takes it all the
time all the time dude double pistas oh
that's on somebody's ass cracked though
a [__] I don't want that no I want it on
my on my crazy cheenos this is what
Brian wants Chef Cheno T I want them on
my
oqu I got heavy obliques though it's
hard do you yeah I do I really do from
like from a lot of torque sports that I
do there chos is it uh that's not her
she has it if if you go to UFC I Bubba I
keep thinking you're thinking of laneno
shf chenko a she's hot see see her gun
what a badass she is you ever SE badass
you ever seen me I thought the tattoo
was more down their
side yeah I don't like it anymore there
might be another tattoo no no no that's
she does have two she's a little bad
that is your Vibe huh it's my vibe I
think she's hot as [__] I like your VI
she got two guns on the side that's
pretty cool 100% date her
100% she's she's I think you have to
fight Jon Jones oh is that
really what uhoh huh oh we leaking the
romance who knew hey dude you going to
quit taxing okay yeah Jesus said you
would never do it I knew it do you are
you religious yeah but a different kind
of religion yeah why talk I go to these
places where where you have to wear that
mask with the beak nose and you go
in I don't think that's really religious
what do you guys do there though a lot
of people are just kind of
like are theying a brew is there a pot
that's I don't really know but a lot of
people are in like the like really cool
like black dud you're you're in a
ceremony um and then a lot of people are
bent over but it's it's it's it's a cool
thing to like meet People You Meet A lot
of people there dude that's a that's a
satanic that kind of and people are
standing up on balconies and [__] are
they worshiping Mo do you ever hear Mo
no idea but um do you see presidents
there oh God a lot of old people old
whes yeah Biden
no that's not it that's
a what would you call the what are they
called isn't it called the skulls don't
they do that I can't talk about it yeah
you're not allowed to talk about skull
bones The Druids that's what it is
it's the skull and skull and bone
societ plebian no I'm not malok I don't
know what [__] broke through
dude yeah I know dude I know it sucks
it's on silent it's not on silent does
that mean one person B your special
no that would be so annoying if I put
that
on I don't know or sad no cuz it would
no because it would go so you're making
some
money I don't talk about
[Laughter]
it ask me are you making money on your
special
it's doing
fine yeah sure moving on yeah that's how
you'd handle that in a in a major
interview yes yes yeah I'd rather be
talking about important things like Gaza
or something you guys yeah my special is
doing
F okay let's talk about I don't know if
even if you made a billion dollars on
your special
I don't believe you would do anything
other than go from your home to
that yeah you may never leave your house
you would just stay in your house and
then you would occasionally go to get
coffee dude Oh you mean turn into Howard
third I don't think he would I he his
hair would be constantly matted in the
back because it would be pressed against
the couch it would just it would start
dread yeah he'd be an eccentric
billionaire his
nails and then you just look at Kristen
and his wife and just be like ah she's
rich but H yeah he's just a I don't know
dude I just [__] you know whatever
it's like I'm I'm all good man
everything's fine yeah yeah is that
interesting yeah but do you you don't go
so you do never go in the sun I'm trying
to live a long time but the sun's
good I go out I get a minute of Sun
every morning you know he used to Tan's
[__] yeah well no I've done it before
yeah yeah you ever done it no oh it
feels good [__] the benefits are
supposed to be pretty good I feels
really good that trend went that Trend
was like there and you kind of on the vi
it just it's just one of those things
that got into the kind of lexicon for a
bit there supposed to on your balls no
not your assh real sens you bend over
and you put your butthole when we go
when I go to my church and they have the
dick noses we go out there A lot of
times it's at night right we have
midnight mask but we go and um this is
not normal in the if we stay there and
get super [__] lit and then in the
morning we'll wake up and assle a lot of
people are are naked and and we show our
buttholes to each other is that what
you're talking about no I
am I love that religious movie Eyes Wide
Shut I
don't it's not I don't know if it's
religious it's about my church
yeah I remember ding ding ding you know
the uh I remember seeing that I'm not
done
oops you know the um himn ding ding ding
yeah the Bell ding
ding
yeah ding
ding it's a piano dude the hymn In The
Eyes Wide Shut the movie about my church
yeah now you can go I was saying when I
saw that movie Y and I saw that those
women in those masks I thought to myself
well what would I have to do to get to a
point where I get invited to those
parties and I think everybody was like
well there's fun and then there's
[__] fun is that Scientology I don't
I don't think so I don't know what it is
if you're Tom Cruz yeah I there are you
tell me you want to do Scientology if
they're like Hey listen we're going to
make you the next Joker you got to jump
on our train like what is what do you
have to do there are parties just
represent no there is there is a there
is a there is one 100% an underground
where there are parties where the
hottest people on the planet are curated
and everybody goes to a house and has
sex that's a fact should we feel sad
we've never been invited I don't think
so because I don't want to go there my
house when I was
32 it it's fun and sad I understand I'm
saying that you didn't invite us I
didn't know you guys you guys were
[__] cucks back there dude hey I was
older don't [__] yeah I know I know I
I there there are parties where it's
like the the Mr off limits here there
are off liit
liit where they play my podcast and then
everybody dude you should your promo for
your image for off limit should be
this like can't bring up my bring up the
bring up the image of my off limits this
is going to blow your mind this is on
your Instagram just type in off limits
with of course it's not just type in off
he's not going to promote it it'll pop
up immediately
this is this isit watch how powerful
this is and tell me who you who it
reminds you oh just type in Off Limits
the show and see what pops up he doesn't
even know how to spell your name dude he
thought it was briab this whole time it
is oh dude get the camera closer no no
not that and get the camera closer to
your face get the one let me just go to
images to see if it pops see what off
limits there it is that's a nice picture
hey hey hey hey
Ken oh I didn't expect it to be that
good
I didn't expect it to
be handsome like that I mean it's good I
it's I like no no no dude don't take it
away from you man this photo
yeah it's great okay thanks but also are
we at your funeral
true that's a picture you would post at
a funeral that's Steve Jobs right there
that's the new oh no you don't have a t
daddy
dude get a funeral that's what we' have
dude dude dude you had it's floating
yeah you're magical dude don't take this
no dude don't be modest thank this
picture is thank
you if I'm looking at it yeah it's
symmetry at its finest you know I
appreciate and I don't no no no no don't
get bful thank you it's a fantastic
portrait thank you it's good I just took
it you know I just no I'm not going to
allow you do that dude I just literally
just said the guy goes can I take a
picture and I was like I was like and I
was like what I go what and he goes you
can take and I went you worked on it for
hours obviously right I didn't I I
literally lit it like crazy I had
literally just famous photographer I
assume I had my workout and then I and
you showered and you got ready yeah I
had my workout I trained martial arts
and then I I had some seared elk and and
I think you must have hired so many
people to get your hair like that no I
just I had half no I had half a
went through the process I really
didn't how many hours of makeup come on
I don't even think I took a show you
know what the best part about it is too
yeah it must have taken yeah a week or
two right to run it through Graphics
because I've never quite seen a
Photoshop job I mean just with the thing
at the bottom I want to to put the mug
there right well it looks like there's a
light behind it it does off limits it's
it's not just static letters is it at
first glance it might be but then you
look at it and you see there's a kind of
a soft effect almost opaque in the back
yeah you see how it's like radiating so
it's like almost like the burning bush
so where where do you get Knowledge
from yeah yeah I know that's what that's
what people do at first you see it and
you're like all it's okay but then you
notice the back and you're just like
well you can
[Music]
keep you keep watching see what you're
trying to do is you're trying to get
perspective you see yeah yeah cuz so it
changes from the different angles that
was built in that was built in that part
was built in that part was buil you see
it you're just like regular font I could
get that online but then when you take
kind of
[Music]
a oh my
God like from there yeah from there from
there from there it's
[Laughter]
different
stupid oh [__] oh [__] dude thank you
thank you thank you yeah thank you so
much and you know that I I'll admit that
that part was that part was put in there
that part was put in there okay all
right and but the picture itself when I
took
it was literally just hit me straight on
here here I am and take what this is
what I got yeah boom right all package
sometimes sometimes magic happens first
take too I assume yeah what
w wow sometimes the first take is the
greatest so you know that from that song
so and that's what I was thinking the
whole time that I I did that so so you
you've got so cuz I wanted to it is
magical and then
see why is he all gray in that
picture and the one you're talking about
the other one cuz this one amazing one
I'm like holy [__] that's my boy not
claim that looks like a funeral shot I
can't believe they shot so that and then
that one there that's of lighting that
one there bad lighting that one there
lighting that one there I hate it no but
it's bad lighting it's bad lightting no
that one there makes me sad I look at
that I go we don't have a lot of time no
no that's not true it's because of no I
look at I go what the [__] am I going to
it's the fluorescent lighting that and I
look at this I go okay got back it's the
florescent lighting hey so hold on so
you have hey Chris look at me you're on
Deck all right hey you're in the batter
box so I got it so you have to so you so
how new is off limits [__] new spank
brand spanking October 10th let's take
another break B I'm be in Chicago
December 8th and 9th and you will be in
North Carolina this weekend come get
some this Thursday Friday Saturday
tickets are going fast and then I got
Calgary Calgary I'll be in Calgary
Alberta uh yuck yucks November 16 17 and
18 been a long time since I've been
there can't wait then I got December 7 8
and N9 in India in Indiana
indianapolis. listen dude the world is
crazy right now with everything going on
inflation War the economy right now
could be the best time ever to diversify
your money and savings with precious
metals like gold or silver did you know
that well gold is a constant so is
silver right and and it's you can
speculate with your money and a lot of
people lose their money so you want at
least part of your financial portfolio
dude I bought some precious medals
myself from gold code dude I bought it
myself and they made it so freaking easy
gold cold has helped thousands of people
place over 2.5 billion in gold and
silver they're rated A+ by the Better
Business Bureau all right they've earned
over 5,000 festar reviews and that's
just mention a few of their
accomplishments there's so many more we
can't do the by the way right now the
fighter and kid listeners they're
offering up to $10,000 in bonus silver
while supplies last go to Gold code.com
fighter tolearn more all right um and so
diversify your portfolio it's probably a
good idea gold code.com
fighter oh it just started yeah that's
great well great taking the podcast
World by storm that's what the world I
say you know what I say there's not
enough there's not enough podcast
podcast and there's not enough good
podcast not enough good podcast yeah you
need hey need information because people
know me for information not comedy cuz I
go Brian Callen Jordan Peterson you
kidding me y Brian well you when you
listen to Brian Callen you'll get you'll
get a lot of what Jordan Peterson said
secondhand and that's and you know what
but I like that but I like you
regurgitate his stuff which makes it
which I'm going to do that anyways so I
might as well listen somebody do that
well well
you [__] agains I go like this I I I
click it on ding I click it off that's
what happens I know
cuz Do or Die the podcast do or I mean
your special grow or Die Do or Die do or
die what am I [__] Bone Thugs in
harmony same thing dude but so good good
stuff but thank you I I will say seem I
had dinner I had dinner with with Peter
teal MH who was the guy who created
PayPal and stuff and you know what I
realized after cre PayPal it was he he
came on afterwards but do you want to
know why I got depressed after I had
dinner with Peter teal is I realized
that everything I say is pretty much
what I've read or heard and that guy
comes up with original thought and that
guy right there that his face right
there was his face during your dinner
listening to
you oh oh he would just yeah he would
just go oh oh yes kind of yeah that's
actually kind of true I spoke too much
but whose information is it I spoke too
much whose information is not
regurgitated by smarter Minds some
people are good at coming up with
thoughts that ideas and Concepts you've
never heard of and then there are people
thank you who no no and then there are
people hey you left your sword just
lying around that's why it's dangerous
don't trip and fall don't trip and fall
yeah dude
um
if there's a what
character
no dies by what character in in movie
history would you have wanted to play uh
why Greg kenar in As Good As It Gets
[__] really great gineer in the one
where he's attached to Matt Damon oh
stuck on stuck on you you love he
is awesome so out of all the actors or
Greg kenar on
I think he's in the gift and also Talk
Soup he was good on that [__] weirdo
no he's great on stuck I like him I like
no he isol yeah what was your question
what's the movie what what what
character would you have liked to have
played and do you think you could have
done
better probably Tom Cruz and uh eyes wi
shut ding
ding ding are you kidding me dude my
acting would be so good through the dick
nose mat
we've done this before you're there
let's do a scene from Eyes Wide Shut
where you realized that I as your wife
enjoyed that sex enjoyed it and might
want to go back hey full transparency
never seen the movie never heard of it
bro it's so good BBA you got to see it
how old is it uh you should see it
that's hold on how old no it's like yeah
it's yeah almost you're right right it's
wild is it about is this about a secret
sex club not really it's weird man it's
it might have it might have missed so
good it's pretty wild well Stanley kubri
who's by accounts the greatest filmmaker
[__] shining Full Metal Jacket can't
really play it right because you're get
demonetized yeah you are you new to
YouTube h no I know you know I was just
going to do it it would have been funny
if the ding ding ding you
know all right Chim what do you got all
right what we gonna do I was just going
to have you go ahead play Tom Cruz goe
where you realize I'm going to say I
enjoyed it and I want to go back and
then I want I want to see your reaction
this is after the sexing yeah and I want
to see and I want you to say and the
only line you have is this oh that's all
you can
say okay okay all right ready and okay I
um have a
confession I enjoyed last night and uh
if I'm 100% honest I I kind of want to
go back
back come on
maning
ding music will come back on ding ding
ding ding ding
oh see keep doing the music ding ding
ding ding
it's really good pretty good it's really
good took a long time to joh one take
dude yeah yeah took a long time to get
either you have to do auditions anymore
do you ever
get oh what what projects we going to be
in a shitty question I'm I'm just trying
to hey let's get to your mustache I was
just trying to let's get I'm the next
Hawkeye
dude well you did get run over by a snow
plow machine oh rer dude that dude's
[__] awesome I love awesome dude is
awesome you're growing a mustache what
are you going to do with that mustache
getting very thick you going my
prediction you want this big twirl yes
you want that yeah reach up I think it
would look good on is that member is
that for movember sure is you sure well
you I think you'd look good with uh the
strong man mustache from go bring up I
don't know if I can grow it all why not
yeah just wait but what how do you do it
keep I think you keep going then it gets
so long you you put wax on go there you
go oh that's me that's you 100% that
should be you 100% anybody who has that
mustache this day and age is a complete
utter
[__] it's just there's nothing you
know you're complete
utter might have thatle just but
sometimes we going to be where are you
though where are you bu but it could be
just a St where we at lows oh oh hi I
see you at lows and you just have that
what you won't talk [__] to that guy but
I respect him either cuz you piece of
[__] no it goes with a certain look now
Taylor manly mustache yeah that's Taylor
yeah mustache he he looks great with a
mustache yeah his is legit is that what
you want cuz you're not growing I can't
grow that why not I I don't think I
could either though I don't I don't have
that you might you might you could have
a mustache 100% but I look like I but I
look like I'm cutting sandwiches in a
deli it's just not it's not romantic got
it it's kind of worn a mustache before
it's like it's awful you know what the
you know get yourself up man you can do
it you can do it yeah oh hey dude oh
thanks guys no dude I mean it you know
who first team especially a picture like
that that we were looking at oh God
beautiful at first I see it I'd be like
I don't know but then when I you know
what I
mean thank you man you know who first
team all mustache is Saddam Hussein bad
guy great mustache can you bring up his
mustache cuz you have those middle
easterners this just so thick dude is
Just For Men it's great for them you got
a bit gray in your mustache all gray oh
really yeah all gray like is all gray
that's why I that's a that's a Stalin
mustache basically Stalin is the one he
you know what I could do that whatever
whatever happened to
him Chris he got he he got hung he's
still yeah he got hung and he talked
[__] even when he's being hung yeah he
did what did he yeah what he said you're
all sheep they were no they were putting
uh they were putting a a thing on you're
not men he said you're not men they were
like you die they was cursing him and he
said
drives a Tesla as a cck it's crazy
you're talking about 90 yeah before
Tesla came he knew about Tesla yeah dude
he said you're not men yeah you're not
men it was actually 2003 2004 was it
that yeah but yeah yeah after 911 that's
why we went for Iraq yeah I remember cuz
I was in it was 2003 when bring that up
CH when did I'm say 03 or 04 it
definitely was 2000s because I was in my
I remember I was in my apartment
yeah oh 2006 holy [__]
he was captured I just graduated college
I wasn't even aware yeah I was just a
young buck dude I didn't care the story
story is not about you it's about Saddam
Hussein dude BR I remember bring up
Stalin you want to see a mustache uh the
worst human being maybe
ever and and Saddam Hussein had a
library on Stalin his hero was Stalin
but then he [__] them over right now
that's a [__] mustache and
hair happen
Chris he died of a heart attack at his
desk after killing probably 40 million
people please be respectful oh okay yeah
now that guy's mustache on the end over
there that top right is that Stalin when
he was young does that scouch Stalin had
yeah that guy wow I can't do that that's
just not in the cards for me looking
dude that's that think about the poor
woman who had kissed that [__] guy uh
poor women yeah just like
this oh God look at the mustaches on on
the
cruel the
cruelty you hang ornaments on it though
yeah he was a horrible
man I it's crazy these pictures are so
like it would have been really cool if
they had like high DEA like you see
those like grainy uh videos when video
first started when they were recording
stuff and then they colorize it you
talking about that world World War II
have you seen it the all the footage
from World War II they put in color I
think it's called World War II in color
you can see you can see Jerusalem in 18
like yeah it's like crazy to see that
[__] yeah I saw from I saw footage from
1100 that they colorized and it was wild
dude Steve Harvey was there running from
like a [__] uh big foot triop triop
terras
whoa my ass triop Terris try it's a
Triceratops took a page out of my book
welc welome the club and you don't have
CT I know no he was making J old though
I forget names all the time but not
Triceratops you knew that you were
making a joke yeah I know he wasn't his
brain literally I'm an amateur
paleontologist I I know everything about
yeah I know everything about you can ask
me anything about dinosaurs I can tell
you everything um okay well how what how
many uh Bones on the outside how many
protruding bones does you know what I'm
going to say stur I know stegosaurus
yeah stegosaurus has 36 bones I don't
know if that's true you have to look it
up um well no you're uh what but you're
you stopped the mustache here and I need
you to grow it here keep going I don't
know why you hand ever feel waves of
sadness you ever feel waves the ocean
like those no no no no no I'm just
talking about everything's
fine you're with people you love and all
of a sudden a wave of sadness hits you
you know what Brian felt it on Sunday no
hope
you ever feel that yes and Bri and Brian
reaches out to me that's called
depression and everything's fine you got
a beautiful life you wouldn't ask for
anything more and all of a
sudden dread hit you like a t of bricks
hey dread where the [__] did you show up
yep hey hey yep H hey dread I'm with my
kids right now take a back seat oh you
won't yeah I'll wait it out yep now that
happen to you a lot now he sure does few
times a day yeah dread day Dre's an
interesting thing yes no yes every day
as
my
yeah Tears of a Clown every day
Christopher yeah of course piss it out
so dread is interesting talking about
Jud dread a lot of people get the case
of the dud judge dreads I am the law I
am the law got a case the judge dreads
but the question is how do you get over
them so one idea is clouds are there
Sun's always there but the clouds there
wait till they pass yes two is practice
what jumping off don't give all the
content from off limits on this podcast
you're right you're right and a lot of
this is off limits unless you pay for it
yeah lot of this is don't give it away
for free just give them a taste give
them a t you do what do you do when you
get a case of the old
that's why he's working out so it hit me
yesterday you know how I know you're
depressed you're
jacked that's funny yeah no I did I I
actually was I felt it yesterday I was
driving and I was like okay I don't want
to go to the gym because I feel sad I'm
going to go to the gym and it's going to
help and I did and it did you're po
you're special that's what special the
best thing you've ever done by far than
and I don't think you could have ever
written that without going through no
way everything no way you had to you had
to grow up yeah no way
no way yeah I I I often was like
thinking about how do I cuz like dude I
I know that the I always want to have a
good time and be silly that that was by
Design dude I I just I didn't like
seriousness I I talk about my special I
didn't want to feel I just wanted to be
funny and it was a defense mechanism and
it was also relief from what I didn't
want to be thinking about and then all
this [__] happened and then I was like
okay I I needed to change my comedy at
some point this is the Catalyst to that
you and so yeah so you would have to do
it no matter what even or not you would
have yeah you can't be I can't be a
60-year-old comedian talking about like
you know the [__] I was talking about
and you know but um but now it's
different and because I yeah I I I let
it I let it change me that's I say you
either grow or die you could either grow
or oh hence the that's 100% true yeah
but do do you think that you started out
as somebody on the Spectrum in terms of
not not a weird I just mean like you
always resonated at a different Tempo
yeah spectrums to Spectrum
but but but but you you definitely you
definitely from the GetGo I think were
different than say your brother your dad
your mom you part of that comes from
being a comic on the outside but even
amongst Comics Chris is different yeah
yeah routine actually very disciplined
yeah but super disciplined but then also
silly
247 you're only interested in that well
I can't I can't keep up I can't keep up
it's tough it's tough though like we're
I'll just shut down it's tough though
like because like you know you you got
to balance it out you know like I I do a
lot of therapy and [__] and it's just
like it's so hard man like I don't want
to do it like that's why you know you
talk about these people like especially
in La they're like don't you just love
going to therapy and you're like what do
you talk about yeah right I leave
crying yeah it shouldn't be a good time
like dude but people are like I love
therapy IAP it's like dude they they got
a cushy life then cuz yeah [__] it's not
fun but you you have to go through that
to get to where you but then be how do
you think it changed you going through
all this [__] you've got more can I
be honest with you at at first when you
first came back like the light was and I
I I I I co-signed it and I you know I
ride with you the light was out and I'm
like and I literally I called him like
what are we going to do dude like you
don't want to be silly with me anymore
like what are we going to do and even it
it did my light going through it cuz we
all went through it so dim even my light
your light when we first came back I was
like oh we're done well you want to
because because it' be like being a
singer and your voice is shot I like
what are we going to do it's because you
you want to die it's because you want to
die yes the only time I've wanted to die
yeah and you know I've and I'm not I'm
such a positive person yeah I know
you're not you you know and nobody wants
to hear that I get it but you do you
want to die and and um and it's hard
it's hard to hard to tell the line yeah
but I think I think the value he watched
a lot of my comedy right I I watched
your comment down a loop what what I
what I what I wanted to do was I I
realized that this was you go through a
lot of loss right you lose things that
won't come back and friends everything
everything everything you lose
everything your ha yeah everything for
real you lose everything flexibility and
what I wanted to do though was I was
like okay I'm in chaos I'm in the middle
of the ocean without a [__] paddle I
don't know how to get back I didn't know
what to do one person battling with you
100% but but you're still alone in this
that's it you're still alone in this
still you're still alone you're still in
this boat and and you have to find a way
cuz I have children and I so there are
people in my life that are way more
important than I was I didn't really
care about myself like like I put me in
a [__] van I'll live you know on a I
don't anywhere I the same way I don't
give a [__] yeah I don't need a lot it's
not me I'm worried about I'm tough I'm
tough but I I I I said to myself um I
said I'm going to try to Suffer Well
what I'm going to try to do is see how
well I can suffer and I don't want
anyone in my family or anybody to know
how bad it is and so I just I just
[__] said I'm gonna never miss a
workout I'm gonna write comedy every
single day and I'm gonna keep assuming
tough to write comedy than especially
when you're in that state of mind I
remember it's almost impossible almost
impossible for me too almost impossible
to find the silliness when you're
dealing with that so much of my comedy
waves so much of my comedy came from Joy
and being part of a community and loving
people I love I L I was always naive
Rogan always said you want to be liked
by everybody and you think everybody's
great and there was an innocent I did
to gone it all gone the Inn but no
because the the battle is to not allow
it to make you bitter the battle is to
not allow it to take your light away
your comedy away your your optimism away
and that's why you need perspective and
you need to realize everybody everyone
who is going for something goes through
chaos every
goes through maybe not but some people
go through Rel it's all different
everyone go experiences [__] differently
you know and so me I was like what I
realized is that I'm I'm I'm [__]
like I realized I'm way tougher than I
thought I was yeah I agree and and uh
you know my father who my father who I
always looked up to his tough said he
said hey come here I want to talk to you
and I said what's going on I was I hate
that [__] I hate that hey come talk to
me I was like oh I don't like this maybe
he's dying I don't know what the [__]
he's going to tell me so I this feeling
of dread and we were walking and he said
uh you know your sister and I were
talking about how how well how how you
protected all of us from what you were
going through how you seemed like you
were totally fine like You' come to
dinner whatever and you you just
suffered through this where we knew you
were going through you lose you lost
everything but you kept riding kept
doing this thing and he said and and my
sister not buming us out no my sister
said did did has anybody told him that
my father said I don't think so so my
father said I couldn't have done that I
couldn't have gone I couldn't have done
what you did so at least I was able to
show myself and the people I care about
I think the biggest learn thing just for
me on the outside looking at what you
guys went through especially was like oh
life isn't fair it's not fair and it you
just got to roll with it it's not going
to be fair yeah but who are you who are
you when whatever happens to anybody
like people go through crazy [__] people
go through way worse oh yeah [__] way
worse well who are you who are you at
the end at on the other side of that cuz
you could lose everything doesn't come
back it's okay it's okay it's all okay
and you're going to make mistakes the
biggest thing is you make mistakes cuz
you're so you're so afraid and you're
desperate I knew you wer give I knew
neither one you were going to give up
and with you like we Jun around how you
can't fight and you know all that stuff
but I knew you're a fighter yeah yeah
yeah the fighter and the fighter you're
not just the kid after all hey you're
not just the kid after all tell my skin
stayed tight though and that's what's so
amazing I just want to say to a lot of
that's the thing I got canell your SK no
there are a lot of got there a lot of
people no no no there neck went I give
up no no no there a lot of people asking
Bri how does your how do you stay so
tight how do you look the same age as
someone who's 40 and 43 and a lot of it
it's just nutrition and I'm selling my
lifestyle for for no well but it's Brian
for $999 you guys for what you get but
you get a lotion packet called off
limits you get yep you get two months of
intense what stuff weekly you're making
it up now you're picking it now
guides to like guides guides and what do
the guides have about it I'm give you
one hint fruits and vegetables that's
everyone knows go deep on your squats
that's you didn't a one-on-one call with
Brian y once a year cold cold plunger
once a year you can call Brian
saunas and most importantly steroids
don't say it I'm gonna please my Lord
and Savior oh no dude what dude Jesus
Christ you got to come to my church dude
I have a mask for you I don't I don't
know dude but the nose is cut out yeah
but no it's got the nose but the why
does this have no backside why am I
wearing chaps but yours have balls under
the
nose me so you're constantly just why
does it say suck what is this what is
this what is this Mass say glory
hole why am I hey dude so you constantly
got balls in your mouth dude cuz you're
sucking
nuts dude that's you man Mr nuts sucker
bro all right no y no I wouldn't be I
wouldn't be sucking as God is my witness
you're a nut
sucker a [__] what was the last thing he
said he said he loved
you that doesn't sound like my husband
did he say you're a nut sucker you and I
both know it said he said you're a nut
sucker eulogy eulogy as I'm delivering
it and then after I'm done with it he
was a great guy uh not a lot of
substance but very funny and never said
anything I learned I didn't learn
anything from him but he was a a good
guy and Kristen's crying and you just
you from the grave you just see this
there there we're going to get through
this together we're going to get through
this together and then Calvin reached
out and I Go Daddy's here no oh what
about Billy huh my other son he's
holding him I'm not as attached to Billy
oh dude now you do that and I go like
this I pop out the
thing you're coming with me
and then you go oh and you would look at
me and you slide down the sword and I go
and you go
o and you're sliding down you go oo oo
and you cough up a little bit of blood
it goes on me and it Go and it's in my
eyes and [__] and oo and you're down
here and you're right there and I just
go
God God what are you doing he's jacking
you bro but I don't have a heart on you
will I'm dying
uh and they're covering
children's in my
[__] so disgusting here lies both of
them the gayest I don't want to be
buried with you God damn it I don't want
that at all so
okay going to just our whole family
going to pull his fingers
everyone you want to pull his fingers
out now I'll leave him there that's
Unholy all right who wants to put that
the guy put the beak mask on should we
burn together the priest the priest with
the finger
just K John John give me a give me a
alcohol swab you any
P all
right yeah and fingers
out CL look pel here it is what it
is he has even touch
anything
um who would be at your funeral who
would be at my
funeral uh the question Chris would you
sell merch at Brian's funeral oh bro
kill it really life rips even in death
dude death
rips would you get my children I tell
yous I'll tell you right now I'll tell
you right now cuz you'll probably you'll
probably die before me I'm going before
anyone here yeah I am selling merch at
your funeral you have my full except off
limits it's still going archive this
[__] and learn is that what you're going
to say off I'm going to have my Square
my Square thing where you can take the
credit cards yep just people I'm going
to hire I'm pays for how my brother do
itz I need to G get your shirts here
just [__] and which one want I'll get
the the death rips one with Brian's
silhouette that's a great picture yeah
he took it you know it took him one time
he took the picture here you go
signature right there if you want a tip
and then uh that's great so thank you
through tears thank you so
much so stupid U I want both of them can
I get a a deal I want both oops I want
both of them can I get a a deal sorry
we're not giving out deals now but here
you go if you want a tip you can and my
son my son like can I get a shirt you're
like ran out yeah yeah yeah I mean
that's good too but I wanted to do my
bit and then you ruin both of them by
doing the thing where you jumped on mine
and wanted that's a good bit cuz my son
is I I understand he's close to you and
oh he ran out of your size Bud we don't
have extra small yeah and then my son
does this I will avenge
him for that's his origin story that's
your son's origin story I will avenge
him the the the long skinny pale one
yeah the crow the man Crow yeah
Dishonored my father so you think that
he goes and trains yeah Montage so you
think that he'll say hey uh do you have
it and I say sorry bud no discounts and
it'll go like this you you think he goes
like
this like that you think that I think
that's a little on the nose I don't know
cuz that's what a vill that's what a
villain does MH so my son's a her he be
a bad guy though so so what's the
difference between a villain and hero in
a movie everybody so you go like nope
see good good guess you say you say to
my son this is what you say you go like
this you go so the kid goes can I can is
there a shirt for me it's my own son and
you go oh I don't have a shirt but I'll
tell you what I do have something
remember me
by and you just you just you gave him
this right a switch blade cut him here
like that and he stays for some reason
but yeah yeah look me up sometimes he
just like this and then hey hey kid hey
yeah yeah yeah yeah and Hey kid hard
candy
right it hits it hit your body my son so
now my son has a choice to be a villain
or a hero oh here's the choice he makes
because my son's a hero a villain says
he hurt me the world hurt me so now I'm
going to grow up to hurt the world right
but my son who's a hero
says I'm going to learn how to become a
warrior and I'm going to make sure that
the world never hurts anyone the way it
hurt me that's Batman hero
does and he goes and he sees the blood
that's League of Shadows yeah and he
that's that's what [__] up man it's
Batman dude yep and then he sees you and
he walks by you cuz you're complicit you
[__] [__] you're supposed be my
friend oh I'm in on it too and he goes
like this he goes you're next his little
hand just hits the side of your face
small skinny hand and goes like that and
he walks away yep and you're just but
it's but it's not like but it's not like
a manly slap it's like a whatever it is
you guys go there's sugar in that slap
right maybe but but it doesn't matter
because 2024 because he goes because
youe guys
go kid but there's something about the
way that kid walks around is he's got
that calend determination you're like
he's like and you hear the kid you hear
my son do this you just hear him
go
no no you
hear he goes
no no he doesn't do that no he doesn't
pee okay he goes he
[Music]
goes hey how long is this origin story
though no cuz his origin story is this
okay what do he do he goes self he
goes that [__] was off limits
yo that's stupid dude no I like it
man not bad complete 360 hey stop
checking your phone it's time right what
do you have to do though I got to do
another Zoom interview okay what are we
are we doing current events or no okay
guys if you want you want you want to
see you want a current event this
weekend in Raleigh North Carolina
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm at good
nights and then I'm in Calgary I'm in
Calgary at yuck yucks the following
weekend can't stop won't stop warm for
with you on Thursday I love that I know
R Forte is going to be there good nights
yuck yucks but are we going to do
current events cuz I was com up to you
guys you guys want to do one let's do
one for sure cuz our boy jelly roll it's
a huge day for him today oh he lost wait
oh my God what' he do no so the biggest
award ceremony in the world for country
music is today the CM and jelly roll is
nominated for five Awards which is the
second to the top so there's only one
person above in Laney Wilson and he's
performing right yeah he's performing
there's be a bunch one person more who's
nominated for more six yeah six so every
other country artist like seconding we
were the first podcast he's ever been on
he's our boy that's my brother from a
very thick you were the one who again
Jelly's been my boy forever people don't
give Brandon credit for how many people
he found he he a million people yeah of
course think about it yeah yeah you
really have remember Mark Norman we were
talking about andw Schultz all those
guys Shane Gillis yeah but they're all
stupid talented they're all amazing no
but you saw the talent I'm not saying we
I don't do it cuz I see tal I saw it
he's such a good guy yeah J's the best
gu the best awesome he's crushed he's so
famous now he's on American Idol he's
good more in America yeah yeah he has
tattoos on his face he's a that's what
I'm looking at and he's crushing it he's
[__] talented though man that's
amazing oh he's so talented the just the
best sure is talented God that's such a
general thing say uh he just got it got
it I jelly rolls open for me uh December
I think 8th and 9th in Chicago really
might be a lot by opening I mean he's
going to open my Instagram story that
shows theic that's cool all right I am
uh in downtown Chicago December 8th and
9th and then January coming in hot to
keep on trucking tour starts in
Nashville on the 25th one night only
then Austin Texas January 26 27th where
you going to be in Austin Fort
Meyers also Fort Meyers and Orlando I'm
here this weekend uh Richmond Virginia
Baltimore Maryland um just Dr it Trenton
New Jersey Philadelphia Reading
Pennsylvania and then Oxnard California
I'm doing some dates and I'm also
setting I have a bunch of dates for next
year coming up get ready guys and go
stream my P podcast my special grow or
die um and uh it's a great special oor
California why the three of us jump up
there go for it come 100% be F you want
to you want to follow me Brian do your
do your 10
minutes do your 10 minutes on my show
hey you want me to come you want me you
want me to open up though you want me to
open up all cylind hey you came and you
did my show at the Laugh Factory it was
you were you were you're you're killing
you were killing yeah doing really well
been doing that since 1995 no that's not
true you were doing some different [__]
you doing you were killing you doing
good you always kill but you were okay
man you forced to be reckon with man
thank you I appreciate
that I know but but yeah but that
picture you took yeah it mag I I get it
now you know thank you man I appreciate
that that's really nice I did you post
that picture I don't know it should be
your thumbnail yeah I think it is and
say from 1940 to 2023 never
mind all right you guys thank you very
much love you guys
and.com get my special new special grow
or die chris.com it's in the coms R it's
in the description it's in the
description love you guys